[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend an diesem
dritten mai Norbert Lehmann ist auch
dabei für den Sport einen schönen guten
Tag das organisierte Verbrechen hat ein
Dämpfer bekommen
Europa weiter Schlag gegen die Mafia in
mehreren Ländern gibt es Razzien und
zahlreiche Festnahmen
angeblicher Angriff auf den Kreml Moskau
behauptet die Ukraine habe den Amtssitz
Putins mit Drohnen beschossen hier
widerspricht
und souveräner Sieg in Freiburg
Titelverteidiger RB Leipzig steht zum
dritten Mal nacheinander im
DFB-Pokalfinale
[Musik]
nicht nur in Deutschland gilt den dran
geht da als die gefährlichste
mafia-gruppe größtenteils unentdeckt
scheffelt sie Milliarden mit kriminellen
Geschäften Drogen Waffen Geldwäsche
heute gelang den Ermittlern europaweit
ein Kuh nach jahrelanger Vorbereitung
schwärmten Beamte in acht Ländern aus
mehr als 100 Verdächtige wurden
festgenommen hat Details
es ist früh am Morgen als die
italienischen Spezialeinheiten in
mehreren Regionen des Landes zuschlagen
im Fokus die kalabrische Mafia die in
dranggitter die Einsatzkräfte Stellen
Kokain Pistolen und 10.000 Euro Bargeld
sicher
neu an den Ermittlungen sind die
verschiedenen Betätigungsfelder der
Mafia internationaler Waffen und
Drogenhandel und
Finanzinvestitionen nicht nur in Italien
sondern auch in Deutschland Portugal und
Frankreich
deshalb schlagen die Ermittler gleich in
mehreren europäischen Ländern zu in
Deutschland durchsucht die Polizei
Eiscafés Restaurants und auch diese
Autoreinigung in München hier sollen die
Verdächtigen Aufträge abgerechnet haben
die es gar nicht gab Geldwäsche mit
schmutzigen mafia-einnahmen das Problem
glaube ich der Mafia Strukturen ist dass
sie teils sehr subtil Arbeiten nicht
offen kriminell sind dass man eben nicht
entdeckt dass es im Geheimen stattfindet
und das ist aber dennoch den
Strafverfolgungsbehörden heute so eine
erfolgreicher Schlag gelungen ist das
ist wirklich ein gutes Zeichen in Autos
wie diesen soll die Mafia Drogen aus den
Niederlanden nach Italien gefahren haben
versteckt im Kofferraum mutmaßlicher
Auftraggeber ein 62-jähriger aus NRW
viel Platz hier werden dann 30 Kilo
Kokain eingebracht von den Tätern das
Versteck wird wieder verschlossen es
wird dann international geschmuggelt und
in Italien so war es in mehreren Fällen
in einer Garage wieder herausgearbeitet
bei den Ermittlungen spielte offenbar
mindestens ein verschlüsseltes Handy
eine wichtige Rolle die Ermittler
konnten es einem Verdächtigen zuordnen
früher nutzten die Mafiosi offenbar kaum
Handys fuhren lieber hunderte Kilometer
mit dem Auto zu Gesprächen doch seit den
corona-reisebeschränkungen hat sich das
geändert ein Vorteil für die Behörden
allein in Deutschland nahmen die
Einsatzkräfte rund 30 mutmaßliche Täter
fest europaweit sind es mehr als 100 für
die Sicherheitsbehörden ist es ein
schwerer Schlag gegen die italienische
Mafia
jetzt zu einer Meldung aus Moskau die
schwer einzuordnen ist der Kreml soll in
der Nacht mit Drohnen angegriffen worden
sein ein versuchter Anschlag auf
Präsident Putin heißt es von dort
verantwortlich sei die Ukraine die
widerspricht und das an einem Tag an dem
auch mehrere Sabotage Akte aus dem
russischen Grenzgebiet gemeldet werden
Sebastian
eine Drohne im Herzen Russlands über den
Dächern des Kreml dann eine Explosion es
ist unklar wer diese Aufnahmen gemacht
hat doch sie sollen zeigen was der Kreml
am Nachmittag offiziell verkündet zwei
unbemannte ukrainische Drohnen hätten
einen Angriff geflogen auf Russland und
auf Präsident Wladimir Putin
wir betrachten diese Aktionen als einen
geplanten Terroranschlag und ein
Attentat auf den Präsidenten das vor dem
Tag des Sieges und der Parade am 9 mai
verübt wurde der Präsident ist bei
diesem Terroranschlag nicht zu Schaden
gekommen
es ist bereits der dritte größere
Vorfall auf russischem Boden binnen
weniger Stunden heute morgen ging ein
öldepot in Gras nur da in Flammen auf
und gestern in Gleis der bei Brians kein
Zug mit Versorgungsgütern wegen einer
Explosion beide Male Beschuldigte
Russland ukrainische Saboteure
der ukrainische Präsident selenski
dementiert heute in Helsinki für die
Drohnenangriffe verantwortlich zu sein
dies sei ein reiner Verteidigungskrieg
man greife in Russland keine Ziele an
attack wir greifen weder Putin noch
Moskau an wir kämpfen auf unserem
Territorium wir verteidigen unsere
Regionen und Städte
und so ist nach wie vor völlig unklar
wer verantwortlich ist für den
mutmaßlichen Angriff zweier Drohnen auf
den Kreml
fragen wir für begar in Moskau wie kann
denn eine Drohne überhaupt durchdringen
zum Hoch gesichert
ja das ist nur eine der vielen offenen
Fragen die wir in dieser Sache haben
andere Fragen wären zum Beispiel wieso
hat der Kreml diese Vorfälle aus der
Nacht erst am Nachmittag publik gemacht
und wieso tauchten dann quasi zeitgleich
auf mehreren Telegramm Kanalen die
Videos der Drohnen auf und wer hat diese
Videos gefilmt klar ist jedenfalls das
Moskau sich Vergeltungsmaßnahmen
vorbehält und zwar so sagt dass dieses
Statement in einer Art und Weise und zu
einem Zeitpunkt die Moskau für
angemessen halten
wenn das ein von Moskau inszenierte
Anschlag wäre welches Interesse könnte
der Kreml daran haben
so eine falls Flag Operation die könnte
zum Beispiel dienen als Rechtfertigung
für eine weitere Eskalation der
russischen Kampfhandlungen in der
Ukraine oder aber sie könnte dafür
genutzt werden um bei der Bevölkerung
mehr Verständnis zu schüren
beispielsweise für eine neue
einberufungswelle oder sogar für die
Ausrufung des Kriegsrechts wir sollten
bei all dem aber nicht aus den Augen
lassen das auch die Ukraine oder
Menschen die mit der Ukraine
sympathisieren für diese Vorfälle
verantwortlich sein können auch wenn
Kiew die Beteiligung abstreitet und sagt
dass es keine militärischen Nutzen aus
solch einer Aktion ziehen würde ein
Angriff auf das Machtzentrum in Moskau
von gegnerischer Seite das würde die
Verletzlichkeit des Krems demonstrieren
und hätte große symbolische Wirkung
danke schön für diese Einschätzung live
aus Moskau für Bewerber das
heute ist Tag der Pressefreiheit da
landet Russland auf Rang 164 von 180
nach Angaben von Reporter ohne Grenzen
wurden dort seit dem Angriff auf die
Ukraine fast sämtliche unabhängige
Medien verboten blockiert und als
sogenannte ausländische Agenten
eingestuft viele Medien schaffende haben
das Land verlassen wer jetzt noch
kritisch berichtet muss mit allem
rechnen zeigt für
Maria niklasova kann ihr zu Hause nur
noch notdürftig verschließen eines
Morgens brachen maskierte Männer die Tür
auf durchsuchten die Wohnungen in einem
Moskauer vor Ort und nahmen ihren Mann
Roman mit seit knapp einem Monat sitzt
der Journalist nun im Gefängnis der
Vorwurf Diskreditierung der Armee
dieses Strafverfahren ist einfach ein
Anlass und mit einem unbequem
Journalisten abzurechnen denn er
beschäftigte sich mit den Problemen in
der Stadt
in drei online Posts soll Roman
sogenannte Fake News über die russische
Armee verbreitet haben
[Musik]
von drei bis fünf Millionen Rubel oder
sogar bis zu 10 Jahren Haft Leute
der Druck auf Journalisten wächst seit
Jahren viele russische Reporter sitzen
im Gefängnis sowie Maria Panama Jenko
und Michael afanasiew vor fünf Wochen
wurde der amerikanische Journalist Erwin
verhaftet wegen Spionage Vorwürfen die
er seine Redaktion und die amerikanische
Regierung weit von sich weisen seit dem
Einmarsch russischer Truppen in die
Ukraine verschärfen immer neue Gesetze
die Lage
viel Hoffnung dass ihr Mann mit einer
Geldstrafe davon kommt hat Maria Niklas
war nicht denn kritische Journalisten
geraten in Russland immer mehr ins
Fadenkreuz der Behörden
hierzulande nehmen wir Pressefreiheit
meist als selbstverständlich doch auch
in Bezug auf Deutschland lässt die
Rangliste von Reporter ohne Grenzen
aufhorchen
denn von den Spitzenplätzen die in
Norwegen Irland und Dänemark einnehmen
hat sich Deutschland weiter entfernt
Platz 21 seit Jahren ein Abwärtstrend im
vergangenen Jahr war es noch Rang 16
2021 sogar Rang 13 ein Grund ist dass
die Gewalt gegen Medienvertreter immer
mehr zunimmt Florian korczyk berichtet
afd-demonstration in Erfurt am Samstag
ein Teilnehmer versucht einen
Journalisten anzugreifen auf den Bildern
ist noch zu sehen wie ein
Security-Mitarbeiter wohl Schlimmeres
verhindert der Reporter erstattet
Anzeige und berichtet von einer immer
aggressiveren Stimmung gegen
Medienschaffende
ich würde mir wünschen direkte
Begleitung auch durch Polizei wir müssen
unseren eigenen Security-Dienst
mitbringen um unsere Arbeit frei machen
zu können die uns grundgesetzlich
garantiert ist das kann und darf
eigentlich so nicht sein körperliche
Angriffe auf Journalistinnen und
Journalisten sind hierzulande zuletzt
deutlich gestiegen im vergangenen Jahr
waren das 103 zwei Drittel davon in
Ostdeutschland zumeist aus
verschwörungsideologischen und
rechtsextremen Kreisen was für ein
Ermittlungen geführt und ich hoffe auch
dass es so eine Verurteilung kommt weil
das ist ganz wichtig das muss ein
deutliches Signal gesendet werden wir
nehmen das nicht hin Angriffe auf
Journalistinnen und schon Journalisten
sind Angriffe auf unsere Demokratie
[Musik]
immer wieder bleibt es nicht beim
beleidigen und bedrohen deshalb fordert
der Deutsche Journalistenverband ein
strikteres Vorgehen der Behörden
wir erleben es jeden Tag auf der Straße
bei Demonstrationen dass wir gewalttätig
angegriffen werden schon im Internet
fängt das an dass wir beschimpft werden
dass sich die Stimmung dann vor Ort
hochschaukelt und es ist wichtig dass
die Polizei uns da konsequent schützt
und diese Konsequenz die fehlt in
manchen Bundesländern oder
Polizeibehörden manchmal Fabian Klaus
will sich nicht einschüchtern lassen und
weiterhin dahin gehen wo er gebraucht
wird um aufzuklären auch wenn es
manchmal brenzlig wird
der Petersberger klimadialog hat seine
Vorbereitung der Weltklimakonferenz im
November beendet Außenministerin bärburg
rief die Teilnehmerstaaten dazu auf in
Dubai festzulegen wie konkret sie die
wind- und Sonnenenergie ausbauen wollen
um das Kanzler scholz sagte es gebe
keine günstigere und sicherere
Energieform als die Erneuerbaren
Kinderehen spätestens in sieben Jahren
sollte es sie laut unentwicklungsplan
nicht mehr geben doch dafür sieht eine
unice-studie wenig Chancen die Zahlen
gehen zwar leicht zurück aber immer noch
werden jedes Jahr rund 12 Millionen
Mädchen zwangsverheiratet weltweit leben
aktuell 640 Millionen Frauen die als
unter 18-Jährige zur Ehe gezwungen
wurden UNICEF befürchtet das krisenkrieg
und Klimawandel die mühsam erreichten
Fortschritte wieder zunichte machen
könnten
2015 kam der dieselskandal ans Licht VW
und auch die Tochter Audi hatten
jahrelang die Abgaswerte von Millionen
Dieselfahrzeugen manipuliert hatten
Kunden und Aufsichtsbehörden betrogen
der damalige audi-Chef Stadler bestritt
bisher sämtliche Vorwürfe heute kündigte
er ein Geständnis an nach mehr als 160
prozessstagen im Gegenzug bleibt im
60-Jährigen eine Haftstrafe erspart
Alexander Pohle
der tiefe Fall des Ruppert Stadler einst
gefeierter audi-Chef hat er wohl
Tausende seiner Kunden betrogen heute
ist klar Stadler wird ein Geständnis
ablegen im Gegenzug hat das Landgericht
dem Angeklagten zugesagt eine Strafe im
Bereich zwischen eineinhalb und zwei
Jahren auf Bewährung zu verhängen und
auch die Auflage die da Angeklagte zu
zahlen hat nämlich 1,1 Millionen Euro
der dieselskandal beschäftigt die Justiz
seit Jahren eine abschalteinrichtung
sorgte auch in vielen Audi-Modellen
dafür dass die auf dem Prüfstand weniger
Schadstoffe ausschließen als im
Straßenverkehr Stadler hatte wohl von
den Manipulationen der Autos gewusst und
Ihren Verkauf dennoch nicht gestoppt
Schaden über 3 Milliarden Euro
jahrelang wurde er als erfolgreicher
Auto Manager gefeiert als audi-Chef
zementiert Stadler dessen Ruf als
Premiummarke neben Mercedes und BMW bis
2015 kann Stadler den Gewinn von Audi
deutlich steigern im selben Jahr muss
Audi zugeben Motoren manipuliert zu
haben lange will Stadler davon nichts
gewusst haben im Spätsommer 2018 wird er
festgenommen das Ende seiner Karriere
mit dem Geständnis des ehemaligen Audi
Chefs wird am 16 Mai gerechnet damit
kommt der wichtigste Prozess im
dieselskandal zum Ende
bei einer Messerattacke auf einem
Berliner Schulhof sind am Nachmittag
zwei Mädchen schwer verletzt worden 87
Jahre alt bei dem Angriff im Stadtteil
Neukölln sollen viele Kinder Augenzeugen
gewesen sein tatverdächtig ist ein
39-jähriger er ließ sich am Tatort
festnehmen wie die Attacke geschah und
welchen Hintergrund sie hat ist noch
unklar
noch weit schlimmer endete ein Amoklauf
an einer Schule in der serbischen
Hauptstadt Belgrad ein Wachmann und acht
Jugendliche starben durch die Hand eines
Mitschülers 13 Jahre ist da alt das
Massaker hatte der junge minoziös
geplant noch auf dem Schulhof wurde er
festgenommen Wolf Christian Ulrich
berichtet
schockiert und traurig fallen sie sich
vor ihrer Schule in die Arme
unvorstellbar wie dieser ganz normale
Mittwoch zum Trauma wurde 9 tote
beklagen sie nach diesem Amoklauf acht
Kinder und ein Wachmann dazu sechs
Verletzte ein Kind und eine Lehrerin in
ernstem Zustand
ich kannte den Wachmann und kenne auch
die Lehrerin wunderbare Menschen
hier wird der mutmaßliche Täter
festgenommen ein 13-Jähriger
Jugendlicher die Waffe eine Pistole
seines Vaters der hatte mit ihm schießen
geübt ist deshalb nun ebenfalls in Haft
der Junge wurde ein ruhiger und guter
Schüler sein Motiv
unklariert alles genau geplant sagt der
polizei-chefin Mittag dies war die Liste
von Kindern der umbringen wollte
der Tatort eine Eliteschule im Zentrum
der serbischen Hauptstadt Belgrad
Serbiens Präsident König am Abend
schärfere Waffengesetze an und
kondoliert den Opfern Serbien ist
vereint in einer Trauer so groß an eine
größere kann man sich nicht erinnern
denn er kommt
am Abend zünden sie Kerzen für die Opfer
an drei Tage Staatstrauer für ein Land
dass diese Amoklauf heute bis ins Mark
erschüttert hat
in Belarus bekommt ein weiterer
Regierungskritiker die harte Hand des
Regimes zu spüren der Blogger Roman Pro
tassewich ist zu acht Jahren Haft
verurteilt worden vor zwei Jahren hatte
Belarus eine Ryanair-Maschine auf dem
Weg nach Litauen in Minsk zur Landung
gezwungen an Bord pro Tasse wird schon
seine Freundin nach der Festnahme
distanzierte er sich im Staatsfernsehen
von seiner Oppositionellen Tätigkeit
diese Aussagen halten Angehörige
allerdings für erzwungen
nach Italien nach Wochen der Dürre im
Norden leidet die Region jetzt unter
starkem Regen in der Emilia Romana gab
es schwere Überschwemmungen zwei
Menschen kamen ums Leben hunderte
mussten aus ihren Häusern gerettet
werden in Bologna der Hauptstadt der
Region wurden zahlreiche überflutete
Straßen gesperrt auch der Bahnverkehr
wurde viele Orts ausgesetzt
und jetzt Fußball DFB-Pokal Norbert
heute Abend das zweite Halbfinale
Stuttgart gegen Frankfurt
ein richtiger
motivations-pokalplatz nach einer
bislang enttäuschenden Saison
auch wenn alles locker aussieht vom
Halbfinale ist Druck auf dem Kessel
Finale Anzug Pflicht für den in der
kritikstehenden Trainer
werden alle Kräfte mobilisieren die wir
haben es sind alles oder nicht Spiel
Unruhe am Main wegen Personalien
kolumenie soll nach adduktorenproblem
wieder spielen ein möglicher Wechsel zu
den Bayern steht weiter im Raum
Vorstandssprecher Axel Hellmann dagegen
bleibt in Frankfurt ob mit oder ohne
Glasner ist offen unruhige Zeiten jetzt
gleich warten wieder erstarkte
Stuttgarter so oder so das Spiel ist
richtungsweisend für alle Beteiligten
Leipzig hat gestern Abend den Finale
Einzug geschafft durch einen Haus hohen
und hoch verdienten Sieg in Freiburg
RB in allen Belangen überlegen hier das
14:0 durch hunko kurz vor dem
Pausenpfiff danach kurze Drangphase der
Freiburger Gregoritsch mit dem einzigen
SC Treffer in der 75 Minute ja und dann
aber das fünf zu eins durch sowas leih
in der Nachspielzeit ein beeindruckender
Auftritt des Titel Verteidigers
ja und ein beeindruckender Weltfußballer
sorgt mal wieder für Schlagzeilen Lionel
Messi nach übereinstimmende
Medienberichten war er nach
Saudi-Arabien gereist ohne Absprachen
mit seinem Verein Paris Saint-Germain
deshalb eine interne zweiwöchige Sperre
das Tischtuch mit PSG offensichtlich
zerschnitten spekuliert wird jetzt über
einen wechselmässiges nach Saudi-Arabien
nach sie sollen
nach Daniel Altmaier hat auch Jan
Lennart Struff das Viertelfinale des ATP
Turniers immer Dritter erreicht gegen
den argentinia Pedro kacin gewann der
Warsteiner in drei Sätzen mit sieben zu
sechs sechs sieben und sechs zu drei
erstmals seit 29 Jahren stehen damit
wieder zwei deutsche bei einem
mastersturnier in der Runde der besten 8
sozusagen auf den Spuren von Boris
Becker und Michael Stich Rom 1994
fehlen noch die Lottozahlen sie lauten
14 15 16 37 42 47 und die Superzahl 1
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
557 morgen gibt es im Norden einige
Wolken sonst wieder viel Sonne die
Details hat gleich öst den terli um
viertel vor zehn begrüßt Sie Marietta
Slomka im heute journal hier übernimmt
morgen Jana pareigis Ihnen einen schönen
Abend noch danke und tschüss und auf
bald
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter viel Sonnenschein
ist morgen angesagt denn das hoch über
Skandinavien löst die meisten Wolken auf
höchstens einige Schleierwolken sind
dabei aber neue Tiefs erreichen uns zum
Freitag und dann kann es tatsächlich
Unwetter geben schauen wir in die Nacht
Davids größtenteils Stern klar sein und
deswegen auch trocken Temperaturen dazu
sinken im Norden tatsächlich noch einmal
unter die Null Gradmarke auf -1° plus 7
Grad gibt es im Südwesten deutlich
milder dort morgen also viel Sonne vor
allem im Westen in der Mitte und nach
Süden hin ganz im Norden sind die Wolken
mal kompakter ja aber dazu steigen die
uv-werte kräftig an vor allem im Süden
sechs bis sieben das ist hoch ansonsten
bei vier bis fünf Schützen Sie sich also
wenn sie längere Zeit in der Sonne sind
die Temperaturen dazu 13 bis 14 Grad
entlang der Küsten und 25 Grad im
Südwesten da gibt's tatsächlich einen
Sommertag die kommenden Tage heftige
Schauer und Gewitter erwarten wir am
Freitag bei 11 bis 23 Grad Samstag gibt
es weitere Schauer und Gewitter und
Sonntag sind erneut Unwetter möglich ein
schönen Abend